>> Hi YouTubers, I am Henrietta Fore, and
I am the director of United States foreign
assistance and the administrator for the U.S.
Agency for International Development. And
we are the largest bi-lateral donor in the
world. And we try to reduce poverty and to
help people who are struggling for freedom
and people who want to build their own lives
and their own nations so that we can have
a better future for all. We've been here in
Davos talking about a number off issues all
of which are very important. Education and
agriculture and finance, but let me tell you
about the global development commons. That
is an idea that is just beginning to take
root upon the donor and developing country
community that you could be a part of. It
is a way for nonprofit organizations and individuals,
and developing county ministers and parents
and school teachers, and people in every walk
of life to come to a commons and talk about
the issues that are important to them. In
the commons you would be able to exchange
information on any issue of importance to
you, but grouped around ideas that come out
of our development community. So ways to increase
prosperity and reduce poverty for the people
in developing countries. We want to have nonprofit
organizations and businesses and governments
all come together on the commons. Let me give
you an example. In the high mountains of Peru
there are a number of coffee growers, these
coffee growers should know a great deal about
how to grow the finest coffee in their world
because coffee prices are rising coffee demand
is rising. All of you probably drink a cup
of coffee at some point of the day and you
want a fine cup of coffee. The buyers are
world wide who want to buy coffee. So if our
farmers who are poor, and who are in remote
regions want to know about what they have
to do to grow the best coffee bean and how
to get it to market, we can get information
to them through the global development commons.
So if you want to keep your eye on this issue
come to www.usaid.gov. Thanks very much, and
be a part of it.